mr. vice president thank you so much for
joining us we really appreciate it thank
you our it's a great day for America so
it's a historic day first time in 30
years last time was during the Reagan
administration tell me the mood in the
West Wing today after a long battle I
think I think all of us just felt very
grateful grateful for the president's
strong leadership here's someone who
literally ran on a commitment to revive
the American economy to make sure that
the Forgotten men and women of this
country were forgotten no more and I
watched this president all year long as
he fought and not only for the largest
tax cut in American history which passed
today but but for the kind of you know
regulatory reform rolling back federal
red tape the kind of releasing of
American energy all the things that have
already revived the American economy but
but to be here for for the largest tax
cut in the history of the country the
kind of tax reform we haven't seen for
31 years and at the same time to repeal
the individual mandate in Obamacare and
open up Anwar to environmentally
responsible drilling is just it's just
humbling for me to be a part of it
Republicans are always known to be
deficit hawks but this legislation by
most estimates does increase the budget
deficit by about 1.5 trillion dollars
what about that over 10 years how
concerned are you about that and does
that mean we're gonna be tackling
entitlements as Paul Ryan always is
wanting to do well I can tell you I mean
the the need for the Congress to always
look for ways to tighten its belt is a
real priority for President Trump but
the the estimates of deficits here are
all all based on some pretty predictable
you know growth estimates going forward
Tax Policy Foundation says it does take
into account growth yeah even if the tax
cuts are permanent they say it adds
about 1.4 oh that's right but but but I
gotta tell you a president Trump really
believes we all do that that by letting
the American people keep more of what
they are but
letting middle-income Americans have
more spending power by lowering taxes on
businesses large and small that that
we're going to outperform those growth
but those growth projections and and
we're gonna see those deficits overcome
by growth but also by exercising the
kind of fiscal responsibility that
President Trump has been driving for
since the first day of this
administration why is the public not
with this bill though polling which you
know I I'm doubtful of some of the
polling but pretty much every poll puts
it between about thirty three percent
and forty two percent a popularity of
this legislation how do you guys go out
now every part of the country and sell
this as a tax cut for the middle class
even though the top twenty percent do
get the lion's share of the relief well
as the president did today on the South
Lawn we're going to continue to make the
case for this middle class miracle I
mean when the president laid out a
vision for historic tax relief this year
he basically said we want to cut taxes
for every American do you have some work
to do here to sell this I think maybe a
little bit I got to tell you when the
American people start to see more in
their paychecks in February and they're
gonna start to realize that that the
president's vision here that this
middle-class miracle that was passed
today by the Congress was an idea whose
time has come and I really do believe
that it's gonna sell itself carried
interest benefits hedge funds they get
to have their profits taxed at a much
lower rate than most Americans that
survives in this legislation that
doesn't seem like you're kind of taking
this new approach to you know to the big
hedge fund op force in the United States
I understand the president wanted it out
of the legislation which Republicans
demanded that it's Dan well look the
president would have been happy to see
it come out but he go to the mat on that
because why should hedge fund guys get
this continued benefit of a low tax rate
how does that how does that look to the
middle class I think what the president
went to the mat on was really just
advancing that vision that he
articulated this spring for tax relief
this economy is already rolling at three
percent growth which people told the
president during the campaign laughed at
they laughed they said I'll take years
to get to three percent he got there by
that by
the third quarter of this year and and
and we're continuing to see growth but I
truly do believe that you're going to
see companies that had had too many
incentives in our old tax code to take
jobs overseas you're going to start
seeing jobs coming back to this country
you're gonna see trillions of dollars
pouring back into this country investing
in American jobs and American workers
and we're gonna see our economy expand
are you surprised mr. vice president
that you didn't get one Democratic vote
not yes yes I am
actually I find that to be actually
stunning even as partisan as things are
yeah
not a single in was there anything that
Republicans could have done Joe Manchin
said he you know it was all behind
closed doors which is not aggravating
maybe he had a list of things that were
never considered yeah Laura that looked
I I watched President Trump bring
Democrat members of the House in the
Senate to the White House so what didn't
work for meetings for meals to sit down
to say we want to work with you well
when you have the the majority of the
members of the Senate Democrats in the
Senate sign a letter last summer taking
themselves completely out of the
equation that that's a disappointment
not just to our administration but to
the American people the American people
want to see the Congress work together
and I promise you you know this
president well he's going to continue to
reach out across the aisle we're gonna
take on issues like welfare reform and
infrastructure next year to rebuild
America you want Paul Ryan to stay as
House Speaker and there was some
scuttlebutt that he might be leaving
sooner than people thought I think the
result of this tax cut really speaks for
itself and the president and I hold
speaker Ryan in the highest regard and
want him to stay in the Congress and
continue to lead the Congress because
we're really just getting started
are you guys willing to do Medicare
reform or is that just too big of a hill
to climb once again well first off the
president made it made it clear during
the campaign we're not going to be
cutting Social Security no god no
changes how can I be
on that on that healthcare bill that we
came close on a couple of times was
fundamental reform in Medicaid I mean
there are ways that that we can find
savings and even improve services to our
most vulnerable Americans in these
programs and I promise you whether it's
Medicaid or other areas the Medicare
Social Security we're not going to touch
those the president's been very clear on
those issues but look a growing economy
and fiscal responsibility giving States
more flexibility to administer programs
like Medicaid as a pathway toward fiscal
solvency we can grow our way out of
twenty trillion dollars in debt though
Vice President we even with four point
nine percent growth that's a that's a
steep cliff we think we we have a
president who has a boundless opinion
about the capacity of the American
people and the strength of the American
economy and and I have no doubt that
what we've seen in this year alone where
the economy is coming back optimism is
back we and all of that is before today
that that as this tax cut takes effect
and takes hold as as people begin to
feel the freedom from that mandate in
Obamacare that was repealed as well
think about that for the last seven
years
the American people have had to pay a
tax if for the for the for the privilege
of not having to buy insurance that
provided them with poor and minimal
coverage